COVERING PARTSTHE HISTORIC
A SHORT TIME LATER, IT DID
BECOME A HURRICAEOCATHN
HOURS AHEAD. IT IS ALREADY TAKE7
, A BETTER OF
WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
SHERIFF THE NIGHT
WENT IN A  TO SEARCH
THE DESTRUCTION.
THIS IS WHAT WE SAW.
>> ALL THAT DEBRIS IS LITTERED
EVERYWHERE.
THIS WAS BUILDING RIGHT
THERE?
>> BUILDINGS, RESTNT
WHAT USED TO BE THE PU.
>> H BACK DOES THE
GOT GOESAIH
THE
SPOYOU SEE
THERE WERE HOMES.
>> I'M SORRY.
SO THESE ON THESE BEACHES HERE,
>> THESE ETHAT YOU
SEE, THOOTT THERE,
THOSE WERE HOMES, THOSE
HOTERE
PROPERTY, TO, THREE, FOUR, FSTOD
BUILDINGS WERE JUST
WASHED UP THERE FOUNDATIONS AND
>> THERE WERE ACTUALLY BOAT
THROWN INTO THE MAIN ROADS.
VEHICLES INSIDE THE WATER,
SUBMERGED. >> THERE IS A IN AANL
>> THAT CAR.LI
>> YOU CSES WERE GHW MANY RESCUE
>> WE HAVE DONE DOZENS.
LOOK TO THE FRONT.ESE ARE MAJOR
THROWN INTO THE BAY.
>>
OH.
INTO THE MANGROVES RIGHT T
>> NOT JUST ONE, BUT DOZENS
THROWN E
>> HOW LONG WILL IT TAKE TO GET
>> WHEN I LOOK AT THIS,
NOT A K
ERM.
WE ARE TALKINGUTREFURBISHING ST
WE T NO
DANCTHROWN INTO
IS HE FROM THMOST DOES NO
LEFT BESYOU  OWITH NO HOES
HO